dans le procès en révision justement de
patrick dils la journée d'aujourd'hui
était crucial
francis heaulme était en effet entendu
comme témoin il a bien reconnu sa
présence sur les lieux du drame mais il
nie en revanche être l'auteur du double
meurtre d'enfants de montigny-lès-metz à
reims clément weill raynal et sanaa
graby extrait au petit matin de la
prison de metz francis heaulme était
convoqué au palais de justice de reims
pour un témoignage hors du commun qui
espéraient la défense de la déposition
du tueur en série qui se désigne comme
l'auteur du double meurtre pour lequel
patrick dils a été condamné il ya 15 ans
à la réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
seule certitude francis heaulme était
bien présent sur les lieux du crime
c'est ce qui a justifié la révision du
procès mais pour la défense et les
parties civiles
cela n'est pas suffisant pour innocenter
patrick 10 une conviction est faite vous
le savez bien
si on ne m'apporte quelque chose on le
verra on est prêtes à assumer nous ça
dit biot sous les 10 bon ben s'il
apporte quelque chose à dire on verra
bien et pour l'instant y'a rien devant
le tribunal holnon confiance que l'
enquête a déjà révélé mais il ne va pas
plus loin
le tueur en série qui n'a plus rien à
perdre égrène le nom de toutes ces
victimes mais clame son innocence pour
les meurtres de cyril et alexandra
retourner vers les parties civiles vers
les familles des victimes y compris vers
l'est surtout vers madame big fish en
luisant madame
vous donne ma parole d'homme que je n'ai
pas tué aux enfants mais quel crédit
apporter à la parole d'un tueur en série
connue pour ses mensonges et son esprit
pervers
pour les avocats de patrick dils la
comparution de francis heaulme était en
tout cas nécessaire
je crois que c'était intéressant pour
les jurés et pour la cour de l'entendre
là même qui s'exprime de le voir
physiquement et visuelles dont je crois
que c'est très important la pression
n'oubliez pas le grand lacombe a scié
les jurés n'ont pas le dossier à nos
questions ils lui rendront un arrêt en
leur intime conviction unis francs
d'après les impressions d'audience
francis heaulme n'a finalement rien dit
rien de nouveau rien qu'on ne
connaissait déjà et qu'ils puissent
faire éclater l'innocence de patrick
dils et les avocats du jeune homme ont
bien conscience que le chemin sera
encore long pour convaincre les jurés de
la cour d'assises de la marne de
prononcer un acquittement
ils feront connaître leur verdict
vendredi